hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about antibiotic resistant
bacteria this is a growing problem for
healthcare around the world and that's
why I think is important to talk about
today let's start by looking at some
common examples of antibiotic resistant
bacteria we've got Staphylococcus aureus
australium difficile and cloves yellow
pneumonia of course there are others but
these are three common ones that you
might hear us now before we start
talking about how they cause disease I
want to emphasize that actually all
three of these bacteria are sometimes
found in part of the human normal
microbial flora
for example that flick aqus aureus is
commonly found in the nose throat on the
skin of many people around the world
without causing infection Clostridium
difficile is often found in low numbers
in the human colon and Klebsiella
pneumoniae is also found in humans
sometimes in the mouth on the skin in
the intestines without really causing
disease however when they do cause
disease they can have some pretty scary
symptoms for example Staphylococcus
aureus can cause sepsis
which is a very serious bacterial
infection of the blood it can also cause
necrotizing infection
necrotizing means flesh-eating so you
can imagine how scary an infection like
that would be now normally you get an
infection with the bacteria you can go
to the doctor you go to the hospital an
antibiotic to treat that infection
however there are strains of staph
aureus that are resistant to make exit
bacteria for example you might have
heard of something called MRSA
that is M r s and stands for
methicillin-resistant staphylococcus
aureus so this is staph aureus that is
resistant to a lot of different drugs
but most notably methicillin which just
a few years ago was one of the most
important antibiotics that we happened
MRSA in the past few years the only
antibiotic we really had to treat it has
been one called
vancomycin but now as you might guess we
have bacteria called versa or any
guesses what that stands for vancomycin
resistant staph aureus so this is staph
aureus that is resistant not only to
methicillin and all of the other things
that Merson is resistant to but also to
thank Mike Simmons so that's becoming a
major problem in the healthcare industry
Clostridium difficile is most known for
causing diarrhea
and of course severe diarrhea can lead
to severe dehydration c-diff is
something you'll also hear it called by
the abbreviation CDF it also can cause
inflammation of the colon called
pseudomembranous colitis
so maybe you can imagine if you get an
infection by Clostridium difficile that
is resistant to antibiotics you have
diarrhea that can't be cured you're
getting very dehydrated you're having
really bad abdominal pain
from something like pseudomembranous
colitis and it's just a very painful
thing to have now plus the Elven ammonia
it is perhaps best known for causing
pneumonia as you might be able to guess
from its name
it can also infect other things though
for example it can infect wounds look if
you cut yourself or you get burned it
can establish an infection that way
and it can also result in bacteremia
this means that if it gets into the
bloodstream it can cause an infection
now recently you may have heard
something called kpc
KP c stands for Klebsiella pneumoniae
carbapenem aced carbapenems are a type
of drug that is normally used to treat
an infection with of Klebsiella KP c is
a type of Klebsiella pneumoniae which
produces an enzyme called carbapenem ace
which actually degrades the carbapenem
drugs that would normally be used to
treat it thus it's resistant and that
reduces the number of antibiotics that
we have to fight an infection like KP c
i want to emphasize that all three of
these types of bacteria if they're able
to establish these infections that we've
talked about and if they can't be
treated appropriately every single one
of them can result in death now all
three of these as well as other types of
antibiotic resistant bacteria are often
called nosocomial infections
what is nosocomial
well it's actually just a fancy word for
hospital of life
basically if you get a nose a komi oula
infection it means that you went to the
hospital for some reason there are many
reasons that we go to the hospital right
maybe we are having a surgery maybe we'd
have gotten a wound that needs treated
we were there to be treated for cancer
to have a baby or many other reasons
what happens is that sometimes you go to
the hospital and while you're there
being treated for one thing you acquire
an infection from hospital staff or from
other patients these are called those of
Komi all infections and all three of
these can be transmitted in this way of
course it's also possible to get them
outside of a hospital in particular MRSA
methicillin-resistant Staph aureus is
known to be transmitted just in the
general
now you might be asking yourself how do
these organisms develop resistance well
there are four main ways that we're
going to talk about today for how these
bacteria are able to be resistant to
different types of drugs the first one
is that some bacteria are able to
produce enzymes like KP seeing the
carbapenem base that are able to degrade
a given drug
another good example of this is bacteria
that can make penicillin eases
penicillin was a very first antibiotic
discovered it was the first one
harnessed for human healthcare to treat
a large number of infections and it was
a very very important drug in its time
unfortunately there are no a lot of
bacteria that make penicillin aces
these are enzymes that cleave the part
of penicillin called the beta-lactam
ring that's basically part of the
chemical structure of penicillin they
cleave that ring and then penicillin can
no longer work normally it inhibits the
synthesis of molecules that are
important for certain types of bacteria
and building their cell wall through
those bacteria have penicillin aces the
penicillin doesn't hurt them another way
that these organisms can use to develop
resistance is by keeping the drug from
reaching its target
for example there is an antibiotic
called tetracycline it works by binding
to the bacterial ribosome and keeping
the ribosomes from synthesizing proteins
that the bacteria needs to survive there
are some bacteria that are resistant to
tetracycline because they're able to
modify it in such a way that it does not
it doesn't ever reach the ribosome so if
it can't reach the ribosome they can't
get through the cytoplasm of the cell to
the ribosome then it can't exert its
effects thus those bacteria are
resistant to tetracycline a third way
that these bacteria can develop
antibiotic resistance is by modifying
the drug targets
so I just told you that the ribosome is
a comment targeted drugs this is because
bacterial ribosomes and human right is
ohms have some fundamental structural
differences so that if you are giving a
human a drug that binds to a bacterial
ribosome there won't be any toxicity
effects for the human host because their
own ribosomes are different this means
that the ribosome is a very important
target for several different classes of
antibiotics but some bacteria can take
their ribosomes which would be the
target of a given drug
and some bacteria can modify the right
zone basically through random mutation
they can end up having ribosomes that
have been changed structurally just
enough that they can still produce the
proteins necessary for these bacteria to
survive but the drugs can no longer bind
to the ribosomes as they would have been
able to originally thus bacteria that
are able to modify ribosomes or other
drug targets in this way are suddenly
able to be resistant to these drugs
the fourth way that we're going to talk
about is by having drug injection pumps
that sounds pretty cool doesn't it
basically the drug injection pumps are
these pumps that are in the cell
membrane and cell wall of bacteria so
that when a drug diffuses into the cell
these drug ejection pumps just pump it
right back out again and so there's
never enough drug in the bacterial cell
to kill it
so it's a fairly cool mechanism but
really not good for us when we're
infected the type of bacteria that can
just get rid of the drugs that we throw
at it
now drug injection pumps they can
actually move from one bacterial cell to
another by way of plasmids in a process
called
conjugation
basically the genes for these drug
ejection pumps are often carried on
plasmids and plasmids can be copied in
one cell and then given to another cell
through this process called conjugation
if you're interested in learning more
about conjugation you can see my other
video that's on that topic in more
detail but basically the drug ejection
pumps are just able to pump those drugs
out and even then the bacteria are
resistant to those drugs now you might
be asking this lecture with a lot of
gloom and doom right look at all these
antibiotic resistant bacteria all of the
mechanisms through which they can become
antibiotic resistant you might be asking
what can we do what can we do to keep
more bacteria from becoming antibiotic
resistant to keep MRSA and versa and kpc
from becoming resistant to even more
kinds of antibiotics well there are a
few ways to do that first it's important
to use antibiotics only when you really
need them so if you're if you're really
sick yes go to the doctor go to the
hospital get some antibiotics to cure
your infection but if you're just
feeling a little under the weather you
don't need to be taking antibiotics
especially if they might not even eat
cific to treat the type of infection
that you may have it's also important to
take the right dose this means that if
your doctor tells you take two
tablespoons of this every day you need
to take two tablespoons not just one if
you take a dose of the antibiotic it is
not enough to kill the bacteria to
actually to actually cure the infection
then you get these bacteria in your body
that they've been exposed to low levels
of these drugs that were not enough to
kill them but were enough to allow them
to acquire resistance through some of
these mechanisms it's also important to
finish the antibiotic regimen that your
doctor prescribes now we've all been
sick before right we've all had
infections and felt bad and gone to our
doctor and gotten an antibiotic and
maybe our doctor tells us take two of
these capsules every day twice a day or
ten days and so we started doing that
but by day five hey I'm feeling better
right I've been taking this medicine and
I'm feeling better now well you've still
got five days without antibiotic regimen
left if your doctor told you to take
this for ten days take it for ten days
otherwise you can have happen what we
just discussed that being that you've
got bacteria in your body that have been
exposed to these drugs but haven't been
killed by them yet because
finish the bull ten days because they've
been exposed in these drugs they had
time sort of built up some resistance
and you can then spread them to other
people because you didn't finish your
antibiotic regimen that you're down
there prescribed finally the fourth way
that we're going to talk about today to
prevent antibiotic resistance is to use
more than one drug at a time sometimes
when you're in the hospital and you've
got a serious infection your doctor
might actually administer two or even
three drugs at a time the reason for
this is because it's very unlikely that
if a bacterial cell can develop
resistance to two or three different
drugs that work through different
mechanisms at the same time so by using
more than one drug at a time you can
help to prevent this antibiotic
resistance of course you should always
consult with a doctor first to figure
out the best treatment regimen for
whatever a given infection may be so
that's all we've got today for
antibiotic resistance I hope you learned
a lot and found it interesting and thank
you for watching our biology professor
videos thanks